hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play the grey
eagle okay we got nothing we got a
letter that's all that we got this is
gigantic cockroach
that's just joining us for this
adventure so what was the point of
coming in this room just reading a
letter about some things that we're
haunting us if there is something in
this room I can't see it cuz I have no
lantern there's probably the final
resting place of whoever wrote that
letter but I'm still in the dark but
there is one more door that we bashed
open with our mighty muscles hi were you
I don't have a lantern
ooh okay hi skull what's back what's
back there stop seriously this is like
the first custom story or anything in
amnesia that I've seen use shadows to
tell the story it's really cool I
appreciate it hi buddy are you there hi
I see you I see you so what you doing
back there what you doing having a
little private moment there don't want
me to bother you I see okay so I can't
get to him apparently I can't even cross
this area cuz the skull is blocking my
path so what was the point of coming in
here this still hasn't helped me like at
all I still have no closer to finding
anything that I was before so why am I
here what was the point of any of that I
didn't get a key how do you get anything
let me get what I now have oil now so
maybe I could find what's this book no
that looked like maybe a clickable book
but no whoa whoa what was that okay no
that's nothing there's nothing here
bones no keys nothing not at all
absolutely freakin nothing Oh here uh uh
right in front of my face I wouldn't
been able to see that because I didn't
have my freaking lantern okay got it
yes all right moving forward this is
good whatever the hell was going on in
those other rooms was bad but this is at
least a little bit good hello the music
has changed a bit why up oh I see okay I
got to thanks for the hint buddy thanks
pal
you're welcome friend who oil I would
have missed that I can I can touch this
but I can't move it okay I need to get
up there so let's start piling just
start throwing things randomly into the
corner hope it sticks maybe I'll have
something to climb on after a while
there we go good enough good enough get
down here let me up let me up look up
alright hang on maybe be a little bit
more coordinated about this huh no no oh
oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah that's it
that's stuff no okay I'm going to go get
more stuff and then I'll be back in a
bit first I'm gonna see what's down here
no thank you
are you coming here coming in here you
wanna man with some of me wait what that
are there too oh god they're two of them
are they gonna fight I hope they do hi
boys no no don't come over here no no no
no no I see you I'm looking right at ya
don't even think about it buddy man I've
never seen one of you up close oh you
are ugly you're all kinds of ugly doofus
stupid [ __ ] yeah oh okay what is he
doing he's he's walking back and forth
okay maybe this is the reason why I go
to the other area but I needed to get
something out of that room I should have
why
Bob no no don't you dare on boy I will
whoa dad did you hear something Oh what
what no that's right you better run okay
so I'm gonna grab this chair see what I
can do with it it's hard to see so I K
it's hard to build stupid a-holes okay
just stay there no stay there stay there
I want to jump on you
I want threw up on you but the stupid
thing is in the way come on come on come
on
I hate stacking things dammit can't get
up there
alright I gotta try to stack them on the
other side screw it we're going to the
other side yeah yeah moose man you're
hearing all sorts of noises they're so
strange I just really wish that I didn't
have to burn some oil to be able to see
where I'm stacking stuff whatever
whatever I don't care
I'm just gonna get here and I'm gonna go
up and I'm gonna get to that thingy and
I'm gonna go home well no you sons a
[ __ ] boxes I hate you so much just let
me up let me up let me up there we go
okay
I thought why is that aeropuerto that's
not in there okay how about it how you
doing you don't look so good
alright you want to come with me alright
sorry
no need to cop an attitude man I was
just trying to help jeez some people I
swear oh they were poopers
there's three of them
I just had a Vietnam flashback to
penumbra hahahaha well done how do you
get these models in here yeah dog okay
that's what that said I was wondering
haha
how do you get these models in here
without this being a full conversion mod
that's what I want to know I want to
know that and now okay that looks like
poison
hang on you see something here what's
over here nothing okay they were all
poopers the doggy was a poo fur
everything's a [ __ ] everything's up
you four [ __ ] in the future I don't
know what I'm doing I just want to go
home and take a nap this is new I
thought the elevator was broken is this
the elevator didn't someone say okay
I'll go down please
no demons thank you didn't the letter
said before that the elevator was broke
hello any demons and out Montek hi hi
hello
now Dave way here today way it was he hi
okay no barely just a nice elevator
transition sequence okie dokie
normally in other games elevators are
used as it missus loading level so I had
to interrupt the flow except in Mass
Effect one where elevators were the bane
of my existence you know I like the
story enough in Mass Effect wanted to
ride all the elevators I still didn't
like it but I just wanted to hear them
all talk so I went out and got every
single combination of my crew that I
could and just bro the elevators up and
down all over the Presidium until
finally I started looping some story but
that was probably a big waste of my time
I shouldn't have done that okay so I
need some I know there's coal already in
here why do I need more why is it so
damn dark I don't know okay there's a
lot of levers missing of places can't
pick that up can't even move that can't
touch that everything here is broken
apparently okay alright are you gonna
give me more oil at any point you've
been really holding out on me and I
don't like it there we go okay that's
one give me another and we'll move on
with our lives another bind here maybe
no okay um okay
why did I suddenly go slower
hello naked dead guy it's not a party
without a naked dead guy not a water
monster party without a naked dead guy
then away was out oh that's not okay
this is one no no no no no no no it's to
show let me ride instead of a [ __ ]
your mother hooker he's stupid [ __ ]
you wouldn't let me run with this thing
yeah I should have known that I was like
why going faster yeah hey my life hey my
life get on there
get on there you son of a [ __ ] let me
heal up and stop wasting oil oh this
game I swear this game I swear I swear
this game
hi hello this looks double extra
securely barricaded so I'm guessing
someone doesn't want me to come in there
or some anyone who doesn't want
something to come out either way still
walking in the darkness hello there cog
in here handle is obviously out of place
okay so what do I do about that I'm
about to run out of oil hello oil please
maybe just a little bit a little bit of
oil I would develop dispatch some device
to control all the doors on the lower
levels now you need not worry for the
safety of the inner sanctuary and other
critical affairs on 4 5 & 6 I also
prepared a spare starter in case of
breakage of the main lever okay what is
it what good does that do me
like many of the things I have read you
haven't told me what good oh no no no
son of a fish ha ha ha
no you won't that's a Justine monster
that's one of the suitors hi how are you
are you good good
go and die in a fire please
okay he's dr. anything I can carry on
with my own life right right he's not
gonna bother me uh care if he hears me
at all I'm not gonna sit around and wait
to die I'm gonna go over here and look
for oil okay big double doors over there
I've got a cog I'm not afraid I use it
oh hi hi oh I gotta go okay trick move
I'm gonna smash him huh let me bring it
up go all right run run run Fred ha ha
drop that oh god I'm dead
yeah I have that one up I dropped I
dropped it I shouldn't have dropped it I
dropped it okay all right oh damn it
okay we're over here are we
well good is my kago get my colleagues
right here okay
goody goody gumdrops happy fun times
what's this door open a bowl oh yeah
I'll do the water I don't want to go in
there so we got the last cog now we can
go to the machine in the darkness cuz I
have no oil the sons of [ __ ] if
people from me can I use this now no the
answer's no oh what's the point of
getting that oh I need the spare handle
that's right I need one more thing sorry
guys I know it's dark but it's bright
out dark for you cuz I'd bump it up in
post but yeah it's all son of a [ __ ]
it's all a son of a [ __ ] so what was
the deal with this mysterious
out-of-place handle is that the thing
that I need to get or what I wasn't it
really anything else here was there I
just heard something Oh someone there
okay
handle crank no dammit what am I
supposed to do what am I supposed to do
I'm gonna be wandering the halls forever
just cuz I have no idea what I'm doing
in about hidden darkness and darkness
oh wait whoa ah oil oil
just a little I don't even think these
are corners anymore they're like v if
anything they're intentionally keeping
oil from me the sons of [ __ ] I swear
these guys just want to see me die now I
still can't find anything this wheel
isn't moving I don't know where the
spare handle is there's a note that said
there was a spare handle but I don't see
no damn spare handle maybe in the water
area I hate to say it but it's probably
in the water area it's over there I
don't know cuz I got out of here very
quickly I'm open that the monster is
gone nothing
splish Splash splish a splashy splashy
anis flashy anything nothing really damn
it
Oh what the hell where am I supposed to
cut give me a gimme gimme gimme
I don't know was that a lever no rope
alrighty then I am at a loss I have no
idea what I'm doing I have no idea where
I'm going I'm going to die here sad
scared and alone where's the spare
handle ok anyway I'll pick this up later
I'm already out of time anyway so I'll
figure this out in the downtime between
episodes so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
ah
Kludd
Oh